اصرف كاش واترك البطاقات ترنديش تحت تيك
توك ومشاهداته بالمليار هو حقيقه صور
اعتقال الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد
ترامب وعشاق ميسي في الارجنتين يفاجئونه
في موعد على العشاء اهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
على تيك توك هذه الايام منتشر ترند جديد
اسمه كاش ستافينج هذا الترند هدفه يعلم
الناس كيف تتحكم في ميزانياتها ومصاريفها
وفكره انه بدل البطاقات نرجع للكاش يعني
تسحب فلوسك كاش وتحطها في مغلفات كل مغلف
تحط فيه مصروف شيء معين والترند بيقول انه
كذا حتوفر فلوس وهتصرف اقل لانه الدفع
بالبطاقه والجوال والساعه اللي تعودنا
ندفع فيهم في السنوات الاخيره هذه صار
مدمرنا على فكره الترند جامع على تيك توك
تقريبا مليار مشاركه
فيلم
اذان
الجديد لكن الكلام عن الفرق بين الدفع
بكاش او بالبطاقه مو جديد فمن زمان بنسمع
التعليقات عن كيف لما ندفع بالبطاقه بنصرف
اكثر بكثير حتى في نكت وميمز كثيره عن انه
الدفع بالكروت والتليفون والساعه يحسسك
كانه فلوسك يعني
نحسب اكثر ايش بندفع احنا حبينا نعرف
رايكم في الموضوع وانه هل لما بتدفعوا
نفسكم بت نفقوا اكثر او لا ويبدو معظمكم
متفق مع الفكره والتراند فاجاباتكم جاءت
كالتالي 77% منكم قالوا نعم الدفع كاش
بخليهم يصرفوا اقل و 23% قالوا لا
نتكلم اكثر في هذا الموضوع معنا في
الاستوديو زميلتنا الجديده في قسم
الاقتصاد نوف حجازي اهلا يا نوف منورتنا
طبعا انت احدث المنضمين للقناه واحدث
المندوبين للقصبه الاقتصاد تحديدا طبعا
دائما بنتمنى لك التوفيق طبعا نورتنا واول
مره تصير معانا كمان انت معارضه لدى
الموضوع
اولا بدي اقول انه انا يعني
مسؤوله عن الصرف ومساريكي وكيف ديري بالك
على الموضوع بس انا بحس انه لو معي كاش ما
عمري بقدر يعني اتابع او تتراك وين صرفت
هذا الكاش
لما يكون مثلا عم بصرف على انه هو تاب تاب
تاب تاب بس كل مره بصرف عم يجيني تاكس مسج
انت صرفتي هالقد على هذا الاماونت باقي
بحسابك هذا الامان
بالعكس دائما بيعطيني انه زي ما بيقولوا
ريالي تيتشك انه باخر اليوم
بصحيك معك
اليوم طيب بس معلش خليني اقول لك كمان شيء
ثاني مثلا في ناس زيي هذه المسجات لما
تيجي كده
فالناس اللي زيي يعني كده يمكن احنا
مختلفين عن انت كل خلفيتك يعني شو شغلك في
البزنس وكده فاكيد حتكوني يعني اوعى مننا
في موضوع ايوه شوي مسؤوله اكثر في موضوع
الفلوس ما تحسي هذا الشيء يعني
لما يفتحوا المحفظه يشوفوا مثلا انا كان
معي هالقد كاش خلص كل الكاش اللي معي وين
راحوا مساريه بس
بضل انه حسب قد انت عامله لي مثل حالك
يعني مثلا لو هلا انت معك هذا الامام
افكاش
خلص هل انت عن جد رح تسيطري على حالك انه
ما تروحي تجيبي كاش تستعملي السيفينز او
فلوس انت مخبيتيها من قبل
لساتني عراقيه بحس انه لما انا باخر اليوم
افتح مثلا ماي بنك اكاونت واشوف انه هالقد
صرفت او بس هالقد ضل معي بفكر انه هي وين
راحوا وين صرفت مصاري فبرجع بشوف مثلا
بالمسجز او عالاب او بما
انا صرفت على هيك وهيك وهيك وهيك وبيطلع
لك بالضبط وينصرفي وين رحتي
هذا المنظر
بس انه للاسف
كمان خليني ارجع اقول لك ليش تفسري الناس
انه فعلا زي ما وصفتي كده انت لما بيفتحوا
المحفظه وبيلاقوا ان الفلوس خلصت انه
بيشعروا انه يعني لا هم صرفوا اكثر
والكلام هذا كله ليش الشعور هذا
نفسيا لما طلعي كاش من محفظتك وتدفعي
بتحسي حالك انه انا
راح تفتح المحفظه او او الظرف اطلعي انه
المصاري فيه قلت فهذا يعني كمان بعطيك
شعور زي كانك مصاريكي عم يخلصوا صح بس
يعني بيعود الامر
شو انت بتفضلي انا بعرف ناس يمكن
بعيلتي ابدا ما بستعملوا
الكوردلي ومتعودين انه خلص هذا الامان او
هذا المبلغ من الكاش ألمة أصرف منه هذا ما
تبقى له
ولكن انا بالنسبه
كثير مرات مثلا بسافر على بلد معين ما بدي
اصرف بالكويت بكون محوله مبلغ مصاري فعلا
ما بعرف وين راح ما بعرف وين صرفت المصاري
على شو صرفتهم
مثلا يعني بيحسسك انه اه نفس المبلغ كانها
نفس العمله عندنا
المبلغ طيب في ناس فعلا كان بياخذوا هذا
القرار لما بيصير عندهم مشاكل في الكريدت
كارد انه يوقفوا الكريدت كارد تماما من
حياتهم وبس يصرفوا اللي موجود عندهم طيب
يعني انت نصيحتك انه نستمر بس نقرا
الرسائل
حقتها ضروري عشان ما يطلع لك صدمه يعني
باخر الشهر شوفي هو انا دائما مصدومه
يوميا مصدومه بموضوع الفلوس ده يوميا
مصدومه واقول لنفسي كيف يا صايره صرتي هذه
الاشياء ولكن المهم تنبسطي الله
ليه بتقولي ده الكلام من اول يا نوفلنا
البدايه اسمي نعيش
في تدخل ممتاز
ما كانت بالعالم شكرا لك كانت معنا
زميلتنا واضح انها حتكون معانا ضيفه
مستمره بعد الكلام الاخيره هذا انه في
حجازي شكرا لك شكرا ساره
[موسيقى]
تحت رعايه الامير عبد العزيز بن سعود وزير
الداخليه تم امس الاربعاء تخريج الدفعه
الرابعه من خريجات الدوره التاهيليه للفرد
الاساسي بكليه الملك فهد الامنيه وحقيقه
على الفيديوهات بتبعت على السعاده والفخر
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
ومن بين اللحظات الرائعه واللي لمست
المشاعر اكثر من غيرها وتم تداولها هي
لحظه اداء الخريجات للقسم
على
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
والله
[تصفيق]
الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب حديث
الناس حاليا في الكل ينتظر نتائج
التحقيقات في القضيه لمتهم فيها بدفع مبلغ
غير قانوني يقدر ب 130 الف دولار للممثله
الاباحيه
علاقتها فيه قبل انتخابات 2016 وكانت
بنفسه كتب منشور على منصه على منصته ثلث
سوشل وقال انه راح يتم اعتقاله يوم
الثلاثاء وطلب من انصاره الاحتجاج وحتى
محكمه من هاتن اللي بتصير فيها التحقيقات
اتحضرت مسبقا لدعوه ترامب وحطت حواجز
تحسبا لاي طارئ ممكن يصير من قبل انصاره
وبينما كل العالم بيستنى نتيجه التحقيقات
انتشرت صور مفاجئه لاعتقال السلطات للترمب
الصور اللي شفتوها الناس تفاجات فيها
وصارت تسال من جد اعتقلوا ترامب او لا
وصار في جدل عن هذا الشيء لحد وصل فيه انه
شرطه نيويورك بعثت للاعلام بيان في ايميل
بتوضح فيه انها ما اعتقلت ابدا وبعد البحث
تبين ان الصور هذه معموله بتقنيه التزييف
العميق او
باستخدام تطبيق خاص للصور اسمه
تستخدم الذكاء الاصطناعي بينشا الصور من
خلال النص واما صاحب الفكره او اللي عمل
هذه الصور اسمه اليت هيجنز مؤسس ومدير
ابداعي وشارك الصور على حسابه على تويتر
وكتب تغريده قال فيها وانا جالس بنتظر
اعتقال ترامب عملت صور لاعتقال ورد على
الناس اللي بيتسائلوا كيف عملوا الصور انه
عبر برنامج متجرني وعلى فكره مو بس عمل
صور لعمليه اعتقال ترامب لا هو تجاوز
الموضوع وعمل صور لترامب وعيلته من جوا
قاعه المحكمه وردت فعل كل واحد فيهم وكمل
كمان وتخيل ترامب في السجن كيف راح يكون
[موسيقى]
اهلا من جديد ضرب زلزال بقوه 6.8 وبعمق
181 كيلو متر معظم انحاء افغانستان
وباكستان وتملت المنصات صور وفيديوهات
للحظات الزلزال والرعب اللي عاشوه الناس
لكن رغم الرعب في ناس حافظت على رباطه
ووقت مقاطع ثبات انفعالي كبير فشفنا مقاطع
لفريد طبي فاجئهم الزلزال وهم في غرفه
العمليات ومع انه انقطعت الكهرباء عليهم
لكنهم بقيوا محافظين على ثباتهم وكملوا
العمليه
[موسيقى]
لا اله الا الله لا اله الا الله
اما الفيديو الثاني
كما قرات الاخبار هو على الهوى واللي
ملفته انه كان بيقرا خبر عن زلزال
افغانستان فقام ضرب زلزال باكستان وهزت
الارض من تحته لكن حافظ على صموده وقوه
قلبه
[موسيقى]
طبعا بيسالوني انه لو انا كنت في نفس
الموقف ايش كنت حسوي والحقيقه انه انا من
ابرز صفاتي يعني المعروف عني الشجاعه فانا
كنت اول وحده حتخرب الحقيقه الاستوديو كنت
اتركهم واهرب من الاستوديو يعني
في عامل دليفري امريكي حقيقه ما يوصف الا
انه مثال في التفاني في العمل خلينا نشوف
ايش سوى
فستان
[ضحك]
معقول اللي شفناه الرجال كان في مهمه
توصيل طرد مثل المعتاد ووصل المجمع السكني
اللي صدفه كان محاصر من الشرطه لانه في
داخل المجمع في مسلح وفي مواجهه بالاسلحه
بينه وبين الشرطه والشرطه محاصره المجمع
مقفلاته والرجال مصر يوصل الطلبيه وبكل
برود كده ماشي بيوصل الطرد يعني وما وقف
الا لما جاء له شرطي انه خلاص يعني يا رجل
اعطينا هات الطرد هاته هاته وانا انه يعني
بس انت امشي يعني
وبالفعل اخذ الشرطي الطرد واعطاء لصاحبه
بس العامل ما اكتفى بهذا الكلام
وقف واخذ صوره دليل انه وصل الطرد والناس
في المجمع هي اللي صورت اللقطه هذه
بالمناسبه ونشرتها واللي بيتسائل يعني
اصلا ايش تكمله القصه فالشرطه فضلت في
المواجهه مع المسلح عشرين ساعه على فكره
وانتهت بانتحار واتضح انه عنده مشاكل
عقليه لكن طلعنا من القصه الماساويه هذه
بمشهد صراحه يعني في شيء من الكوميديا
السوداء يعني
ما اقدر العب الارجنتيني بطل كاس العالم
ليونيل ميسي من انه ينهي وجبه العشاء هو
وعيلته في مطعم بالارجنتين في مطعم في
العاصمه الارجنتينيه تحديدا يونس بسلام
وسبب مو مشكله صارت معاه ولا حدث طارئ
اللي صار فعليا انه محبين وعرفوا انه ميسي
في المطعم وهكذا كان المشهد
[تصفيق]
قولي اللي بيسال كيف قدر ميسي وعيلته
ويطلعوا من المطعم فمسي طلع من المكان وهو
مبتسم ومبسوط بس بحراسه امنيه تحسبا
لسلامته هو وعائلته
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا احنا وصلنا خلال او للختام حلقه
اليوم بكره ان شاء الله حيكون رمضان فكل
عام وانتم جميعا بالف خير ومثل كل سنه
تفاعلكم حيكون معكم ان شاء الله في رمضان
ومخبي لكم احلى المواضيع والنجوم خلال
الشهر الفضيل تابعونا خلال رمضان لكن
مشاهدينا في موعدنا الرمضاني حيتغير
موعدنا وحيصير 12 منتصف الليل بتوقيت
السعوديه مشاهدينا انا القاكم غدا ان شاء
الله في موعدنا الجديد وكل عام وانتم بالف
الف خير
[موسيقى]